myanmar's governing national league for
democracy party led by aung san tsuchi
has claimed another landslide victory in
general elections
official results are yet to be released
but the nld says it's confident it has
won enough seats to be able to form a
new government
i'm so happy and thrilled that nld has
won
i believe our mother sue will make the
best situation for our country
i voted for nld because i want the best
for my country
i hope all newly elected candidates will
listen to the ordinary citizens who
voted for them
celebrations began soon after polls
closed
despite pleas from the government to
return home a sea of supporters clad in
red
put aside their fears about the pandemic
and gathered to show
support for the governing party
despite widespread vote cancellation in
ethnic areas and speculation
that covert 19 would keep people away
from the polls
the turnout on election day was high
voting is still new in myanmar for most
voters this is only the second time in
their lives that they've had a chance to
vote
for the party of their choice and so
people don't take this for granted
even if they feel that the nld is going
to win in their constituency
they still want to get out there to
demonstrate their support to do their
civic duty and i think there was an
overwhelming sense of that
and for the nld it looks like enthusiasm
for the vote
has been reflected in the result 25
of the seats in myanmar's parliament are
reserved for the military
so that means that the nld needed
two-thirds of the seats being contested
in this election
in order to gain enough power to choose
the president who then in turn
will form the government although the
nld was widely expected to win
there was a question about whether it
would gain enough seats to meet that
threshold
but it seems the party has exceeded
expectations ali fal
al jazeera yangon